[Music]  I'm watching you you will have to  remember someone down there  he wasn't human the known terror and he  killed again  they didn't just kill them hacked into  the Rory is everywhere and the more I  will find him and I will kill him  [Music]  you never talk about your past don't  remember the fragment there was an  attack  you were dying we saved you and now you  save others  everything they told you what a lie you  had a family remember that but I what a  beauty you are  what do you want for me  they did not save your life they stole  it  how many were there before me  she was the post had a clean-burning i  order you determinate  thank you  they created me but they cannot control  me  you  you